quiet quiet everybody everybody quiet
she trying to meditate hey how you doing
hey how you doing I'm 2 Chainz what's up
many Alberta it's the beautiful
Charlotte sure let let's make sure
what's up go talk to it this is the own
meditation pod like some space-age type
of flavor like you decide you could fly
I can't reply that had to climb so tell
me what what does this thing have to
offer I mean what's going on with the
meditation I see the pillows I see the
you know I see the shape of light this
is to help facilitate meditation this
mimics the environment of being out in
nature of using sound light vibration
and I get that yeah yeah the proper
title for this is a meditation part
what's your definition of meditation
like how do you define meditation well
meditation for me is it's a it's a state
of mind
I'm feeling a bit elevated that's what I
was thinking feeling elevated just how
do you see this is exactly well I'm
actually I'm like you know I don't you
constantly meditating
hmm our role is delicious yeah I mean
you want to try thing you need to try
Charlotte like in there to feel the full
the full vive avec is like you have to
be facing that way away walk the other
way right got a look like it's about
what you got to look that way yeah she's
gotta look that way I don't do right
right we'll see well if she looks this
way she's not gonna get the familiar
with the Angela yeah right
alright good in should I turn this way
right so you're gonna sit right here sit
on right put your legs yeah gonna need
some help oh but where do I put I don't
want to get it dirty
well that's sorry don't worry about
what's the cleaning process for this I'm
serious do you put like some kind of
like dry cleaners okay just drop it all
listen my nails do it that's right
sounds like some me [ __ ] alright kind of
dizzy a bit I was doing something to you
sir what does it thing you're just
staring at white right is it vibrating
or something no I'm not getting that yet
well okay next question okay what would
something like this cost this one 60,000
well lion fan let me get out of there no
that's alright that's alright sixty
thousand sixteen sixteen thousand it's
really a still a lot of money breast a
lot of cake well right but we got to
make it
we got to make a larger one for you so
it's gonna be about 30 grand
their goal level 60 grand I think it's
here I need to get that 16 price okay
alright alright alright and the 30 you
know what I think you could fit listen
listen they're gonna look like you had a
dirt bike in it I'm not going in there
like that
hey look man I tell the truth this was a
pleasure hit thing be on the water
it's about to be the next thing I feel
like that's gonna be the next way what's
your thing sugar I dig it
I was just explaining to our Berto what
idea to meditate I was able to host my
most beautiful Charlotte very talented
and you know he had this meditation pot
you know that plate music had sound
vibration you know I'm saying the price
was around 20,000 for me I mean although
I'm having it it's still a little steep
so you let me know
are you down with that campaign true